[Music]
tucker uh i think it's fair to say
you've encountered quite a lot of
criticism
in recent days because as far as i can
figure out you are the only
mainstream
host
who is skeptical of the idea that
president biden
needs to interfere militarily
if vladimir putin invades ukraine
and for that you have been called a
russian spy
a russian asset
democratic politicians have said
that you are um your viewers are calling
them up to tell them that you're on
russia's side
how do you answer this charge that you
are on
the side of an evil authoritarian
with the chuckle
um
but what's interesting
is
the presumption in the united states is
that it's
you know terrible to be an asset of
russia but
entirely acceptable to be an asset of
ukraine
and and many of course in washington are
the president's own son worked for
ukrainian company and the president
himself was deeply enmatched in the
internal politics of ukraine when he was
vice president and of course still today
and i'm not sure why that's better
you know no one in the united states
ought to be an agent of a foreign power
or
promoting foreign interests at the
expense of america's interests i mean in
a democracy it's very simple the
government exists to serve the people
who put it in power by voting
and your foreign policy ought to reflect
that which is to say your foreign policy
ought to serve the interests of the
country now if it's ancillary effects or
improve the lives of others then that's
that's certainly great and virtuous
but if its primary goal is to
serve the interests of other countries
or their populations then it's by
definition illegitimate i mean that's
the you know that's the role of church
groups and ngos and you know there are
plenty of humanitarian organizations but
the us military the united states state
department the white house the us
congress even our media
exists for the benefit of the united
states period and they've lost sight of
that and that's the promise the argument
i'm making against
intervening between ukraine and russia
we already have by the way we've said
billions in what we're now calling
lethal weapons
as opposed to what i suppose but um
missile systems and small arms and all
kinds of stuff
to ukraine into neighboring countries
you know we're already funding a proxy
war
so
why would we be doing that i mean is
there a vital american interest that
serves perhaps there is i haven't heard
anyone explain it
and you sort of know if they go
immediately to you're working for
vladimir putin or something i've like
limited interest in vladimir putin i've
never been to russia i don't speak
russian
much less ukrainian it's just not a part
of the world that is captured by
interest but even if it had to answer my
question
right i mean like what is the vital
interest at stake and of course they
they can't answer it so they go ad
hominem immediately to me that's a very
obvious sign
of their weakness if you become
hysterical when someone asks you why
you're doing something then maybe you're
doing the wrong thing
well perhaps there's a certain
insecurity about nato uh and
particularly among in britain i know uh
there's a strong desire to sustain nato
even though the primary purpose of nato
uh to win the cold war has gone
uh and do you think there's an argument
a legitimate argument to be said that if
we allow uh putin to expand into eastern
europe into non-nato powers then he will
be
buttering buffering up against
uh nato powers that we are committed by
treaty to support and america is
committed by treaty to support so
it it puts
russia and the west
at a sort of trigger point that they
aren't at the moment
okay well i i mean i guess but that
would be a voluntary trigger i assume
i mean i think it's important given that
the soviet union collapsed when i was on
my honeymoon that was 30 years ago i
mean the full collapse happened in
august of 1991 that was the point it was
my and my father worked for the us
government waging the cold war so that
was at the very center of our family's
conversations every night
at the very same moment that many of
these now russia hawks were making
excuses for the soviets i should point
out irony of ironies but in any case
it was a secular regime then it's a
regime that subsidizes the orthodox
church now so maybe that's the
difference
just to guess
but but in any case
at that point
you know you'd think someone say okay we
have all these post-war institutions
that have i think very effectively maybe
even valiantly serve their purpose they
kept the soviets from invading western
europe that's great
i was always for that always for nato
but at this point what is their purpose
maybe we repurpose them we recite we
have a standing army called nato so
maybe we do something new with it but no
one ever
kind of articulated what the new purpose
is
and that's a huge problem if you have i
mean this is a thing something that you
know anyone who covers washington where
i was for 35 years sees every single day
these zombie institutions marching
forward toward what no one will ever say
their original purpose has either
disappeared
or they failed to achieve it they've
been proven ineffective at doing what
they were designed to do but they
continue because they're well funded
that's fine if it's the head start
program which was designed in 1965 to
raise the iq of poor kids it didn't work
but we still have it
but if you have an army if you have a
military alliance called nato
i don't know that could be really
disruptive unless you have a clear goal
i mean this used to be prerequisite for
all military action
define articulate the goal make it very
clear to all participants that's what
we're attempting to do
imperial japan we will not stop until
you proffer and we accept your
unconditional surrender they wouldn't we
dropped the atom bomb on two of their
cities okay got it now you could agree
or disagree with what we did
but the goal was never in doubt it was
unconditional surrender so what is the
goal of nato exactly
to protect ukraine it's not a member i
mean the whole thing is so
so so crazy and childish i
anyway you see that if i mean if if as
as some people suggest one day you might
be if you were president of the united
states would you say let's scrap nato
you know as it can as an instinctive
conservative i'm against breaking things
without a good reason so you have i
think the first thing i do is assess
your we have this thing we have this
military alliance
it's awfully well funded
and awfully well armed relatively
speaking
and is there something useful we could
do with that and and i think it would be
worth pausing i have not i've been
thinking about this for you know fairly
intently for four years since putin
three and a half years met with
trump in helsinki i was there and this
was this was a big topic like what's the
point of nato and i have not met anyone
who can explain how we could do
something useful with nato
um
does anyone sincerely believe that
western europe is at risk
of being invaded by putin well if it is
then
western european nations which i think
we at this point can trust to have
weapons
should defend themselves i mean that's
the idea of the nation state you defend
your own interests you have a vested
interest you have what we call skin in
the game and you want to defend it if
it's worth something to you
and that system has kind of worked
fairly well
well i mean i don't want to sound like a
i don't want to sound like a hawk
because i don't think i am but i mean i
suppose the theory would be
if let's say putin somehow takes over
ukraine which again is is doubtful
uh he would then be
up against the baltic states some of
which are uh
some
nato members so what how would you how
would you
deal with that would you say that if he
invades a baltic state does that become
a different question i would i'm not
sure i would deal with i mean as from
the american look i'm an american
i have no other passport i've got four
kids four dogs in a house i'm not going
anywhere so from my perspective is
wholly american and i think every
country has a different perspective
that's why i was from brexit you know
and each country should be able to
represent its own perspective on the
world stage that's like a baseline view
for me so from an american perspective
i would say is it you know given the
competing nature of interests
is it in the top tier of interests to
prevent russian expansion in eastern
europe i mean it's not something you'd
wish you want free people to live in
freedom on the other hand the freedom of
people's threatened the world over there
are ongoing border disputes in africa
the continent that i'm actually
interested in
that have been you know
going on grinding on causing the deaths
of literally millions
for decades and you know that's sad
nobody wants it to be the case but is it
in our interest to physically prevent it
or try to we also have a terrible record
of actually affecting the desired
outcomes
we just withdrew from afghanistan
this fall after the longest war in
american history and rather than pausing
to ask why didn't that go as expected
what are the mistakes we made what are
the assumptions that led to those
mistakes we're on to you know
contemplating an invasion of russia
during winter
because that works anyway this is very
the threats to the united states and the
uh our interests
global trade routes energy
pure like military power relative uh
relative military power comes from china
of course
and so to the extent that you are
focused on another region given the size
of our military our attention span the
limits of our budget you are detracting
from that and so the question is is it
worth it
and being american we're not trained to
think that way we imagine everything is
a possibility the world's a menu of
endless possibilities we can do all of
it
but the truth is we can't never have
been able to there are limits of you
know physics and money and
and reality that impose on you and so
of course i wish latvia the best i would
feel sad if latvia ever lost its
autonomy to the extent it actually has
autonomy as a nano member but whatever
i would say to myself
you know that's sad is it
but is intervening given the realistic
possibilities of doing what we want to
do
worth it
given that that would detract from the
real problems which are east not eastern
europe but far east so that's how i
would think about it i think that's a
pretty moderate
sensible realistic way to think about
anything i don't think that's radical i
certainly don't think it's taking
putin's side i have no
i have no special interest in any of
this i only care about my country
well it's interesting you mentioned
china because i mean there's a lot of
talk in foreign policy circles about the
pacific pivot over the last 20 years in
america and how america's strategic
focus now has to move to the pacific
rather than to europe the middle east uh
and eastern europe
uh
and of course the pacific pivot does
actually challenge china i mean it does
challenge china's ambition so
it does presumably suit china for
america to be focused
on uh the ukraine
because it means they care a little bit
less about what china's doing in say the
south china sea or something like that
needless to say
so and you could you know look i'm not
alleging any conspiracy here i do think
there is a feature of human nature
that causes and i think it's innate that
causes people when confronted with an
unsolvable problem to turn to something
else
to occupy their minds
and anyone who's been i mean this is
relevant to your viewers who are
journalists anyone's ever been on
deadline for say a magazine piece will
find himself surely tempted to rearrange
his books by offer
because it's it's another problem to
work on as you ignore the problem that
confronts you that you actually can't
solve
china is a problem that is very hard for
the united states to solve
and it's not clear how we do solve that
problem by problem i mean
you know sort of giving hegemony of over
the world to a country that doesn't
believe anything really that we believe
it would be a massive change in the way
the world operates in the way that we in
the united states live and the way that
you and great britain live i mean having
china in charge of the world would be
very different from what we have now
that's a huge concern a legitimate
concern i think
um and we're not meaningfully dealing
with it and i think
you know part you often hear people on
the right say well that's because
they're all taking money from china well
yes that's true
our former secretary of state madeleine
albright was like a [ __ ] by the way but
got rich as so many have been
but you know got rich
effectively making china's case to the
american business community many others
in our diplomatic world have done the
same so that's a that's a straight-up
sellout hollywood sells out the nba
sells out they're controlled by the
chinese government everyone knows that
but i think the deeper problem has
nothing to do with commerce it just has
to do with
the terrifying nature of this threat
and our own fear that we can't actually
do anything about it so here's where i
would start
not that i make these decisions
but it's not a question of pivoting east
china has
massive influence within our hemisphere
go to any island in the caribbean
including the american colonies there we
call them protectorates or their
colonies
saint croix virgin islands for example
all the infrastructure in san cros
what
why would china be building the airport
and the roads in saint croix and why are
they doing the same in jamaica and haiti
and virtually every population center in
the caribbean also true in south america
again this is our hemisphere
which for more than 200 years we've said
explicitly we control we will not allow
you know world powers from across the
oceans to control you know anything of
meaning in our hemisphere and yet they
are and this is being completely i never
heard anybody mention it
i just noticed it from traveling a lot
so i would just start there and say you
know what is this about
maybe it's totally benign that they're
building the infrastructure in bolivia
maybe it's not well also i mean if if
you were designing american global
strategy you would think if you were
george kennan or something you would
think
isolating china would be good therefore
splitting russia off from china would be
good
except for the fact that america's
rhetoric at the moment seems to be
driving russia to and china together as
as quickly as possible
what's and that is of course the effect
i i personally believe it's one of the
intended effects
but what's so fascinating to me and so
repugnant
is that clearly there are many people in
positions of power in the united states
who sincerely believe that we have more
in common with china and this government
than the government of russia now this
is in no way a defense of the way the
putin government operates you'll notice
i don't live there i don't care to i
feel sorry for ed snowden who's stuck
there etc etc
but
if we're being honest and we always
should be
we have far more in common with russia
than we have with china i mean
russia is a christian country no it's
not any kind of evangelical country or
morally upright country i'm not right
but its culture is rooted in western
civilization which is another way of
saying we never say it but it's true
christian
civilization and christianity i mean its
presuppositions are christian whether it
lives up to them often it doesn't the
darkest period in russian history was
the period when it ceased to be russian
and became
soviet and
you know anyway you see the point so
for our leaders who are very familiar
with how both of those countries work to
look at the world and say
you know
we're on china's side which is
absolutely what they're saying reveals
something horrifying about them
again that's a you could say you know i
hate putin i hate the way he runs that
government
but really compared to what i mean
that's the other compared to what this
is a nasty world
filled with you know genocidal lunatics
at the helm not simply of two or three
countries but of a lot of countries and
the only reason they're not committing
genocide is to zone the power to but a
lot of bad people in charge always have
been
so to decide that putin is the worst of
the lot like you're lying actually or
you're totally ignorant
well you're bringing up of christianity
and western culture brings up another
accusation that is often made against
you which is that you are uh rousing the
forces of ethno-nationalism
uh how do you respond when people say
that to you
ethno
i mean that's one of those phrases that
the sort of half-wits in charge of the
atlantic magazine throw around without
thinking about
ethnonationalism i don't know i don't
even know what my ethnicity is i'm like
half swedish half english i guess it's
not of great interest to me i can tell
you that i'm an american i don't think
in ethnic terms i wasn't raised that way
at all um and i still don't and i resist
all
pressure too
pressure mostly from the left to
categorize myself and everybody is a
member of some community or
racial group i hate that [ __ ] and i will
never participate in it so but i would
say what's so interesting
is that the same people who are saying
you know
opposing war with russia over ukraine is
ethnonationalism or simultaneously
making the case that ukraine is for
ukrainians
and then the russians have have no right
to enter so our country we had two
million
immigrants unauthorized illegal without
documents whatever you call them
commenced this country in the last
calendar year 2021 2 million
that's like four times the size of the
city of boston that's a massive number
of people okay
even in a country of 345 million so a
lot of people unprecedented
and the pre the justification for this
is well borders are racist people have a
right to go wherever they want in search
of a better life
here i'm looking at tens of thousands of
russian citizens masked on the ukrainian
border hoping to get in for a better
life
and i'm seeing world leaders say no
you're not allowed to do that ukraine is
for ukrainians i mean speaking of
ethno-nationalism why is it if we can
import thousands of haitians illegally
why is it
such a lift for the ukrainians to just
you know let several thousand russians
in
obviously i'm joking sort of i mean of
course i'm joking but i also think like
that's
that's a ridiculous i mean speaking of
ethno nationals what's the largest
ethno-nationalist nation in the world
well it's their closest ally china
china is an ethno state it's run by and
for the chinese why do you think the
weakers are getting so much trouble why
do you think that you know the
mongolians and the tibetans because
they're not han chinese
so look i i'm not you know you run your
country as you want i'm not really much
of a judger actually i judge my own
country because i live here
but the same people you know bill
crystal was like
he's like an idiot there's no
nationalism fascism okay got it got it
built a guy who couldn't even run a
small circulation magazine is like i'm
in charge of american foreign policy
think about what you're saying
i mean it's like it's it's ridiculous
and so there are many ridiculous people
i'm ridiculous sometimes i get it i have
a high tolerance for ridiculousness it's
the seriousness with which ludicrous
people are taken that really scares me
we have a big important country you
can't
allow
dumb people to act stupidly
without you know reacting to it it's
like what uh it really freaks me out how
mediocre our leadership class it's not
just that they're wrong
but they're like low iq it's like bill
crystal is considered an intellectual
really on the basis of what
what no
do you do you now deliberately uh
organize your program to trigger their
rage i mean for instance you have this
no no no i don't i mean one thing i do i
i don't and by the way if i'm being
honest
you know i don't have a great sense of
their rage because i don't you know i
don't like the internet it hasn't made
me smarter you know i really i make it
affirmative effort to turn off all the
garbage devices i don't own a tv but i
have an ipad and a phone
you know that's my whole electronics
right here and i turn that stuff off at
night and i read books
you know nothing nothing crazy but i
read you know non-fiction books at night
and so i don't i just don't like i don't
think the internet has made us wiser or
even better informed
um and so i don't go on like social
media i don't know on twitter reading
about myself or whatever i don't really
know did you let people say and i'm not
that interested if there's something
important someone i love will tell me
and i'll listen carefully but
like what if david frum is mad like i
worked with david frum for six years i
know david frum really well
yeah david frum is mad at me i mean fine
you know what i mean i i don't care why
would i care did you miss i hope you
didn't miss uh sorry to move off global
politics completely the reaction to your
eminem
eminem's
segment on social media it's so funny
you said it yeah i missed it completely
and the only reason i know anything
about it is because one of my producers
called me today and said this morning
and said
let's do a follow-up on that eminem
segment which i wrote in and i'm not
exaggerating like
six minutes i mean it was nothing let's
explain this
80 words in that let's explain to
british viewers what that was that uh
that something happened with eminent one
of the m ms that made them
there was that it was so the m m eminem
mars the company that makes
m m's which are in case you don't have
them in the uk delightful chocolate
candies yeah i'm as you can probably
tell i'm a big i love candy
anyway so they come out and they're like
okay our cartoon characters which have
been a feature of our advertising for a
long time
and they're just like little round
chocolate candies with legs
um we have realized through some deep
reflection that they're sexist
and the female
characters are wearing like sexy boots
and now because women matter and women
in leadership are so important we're
going to put them in frumpy flat sold
shoes
and so like okay
again i'm a personally a supporter of
the m m's company i mean i
single-handedly keep their stock price
high so i'm not against m ms
but i just made the point that like
women can be in leadership and still
wear sexy boots
there's like nothing there's nothing
inherently contradictory about that you
can have
women who are still feminine or whatever
leading things and i just i was mocking
i was just mocking i was just joking i
mean i you know uh but apparently people
got all
got all exercised
fine with me
well i think from uh ethno nationalism
to candy i think we
we've covered quite a lot
can i just say one thing i i just always
think this i do have some pretty
far out views on a couple of different
things but they're not
related to anything political
yeah you know i have really strong views
about nature or whatever um that are not
mainstream views
however my views on like race or sex or
foreign policy are like
completely moderate
middle of the road you know 10 years ago
my views were not even interesting
enough to mention yes and my views
really haven't changed so it's just so
funny to be like this radical putin
apologist racist
no
i'm more i'm much more conventional than
that what is your most far out view
i hate drywall
i i really don't like unnatural building
materials i really believe in wood and
i'm an extremist on the subject and i
won't
live in or spend any time in a room
whose walls are covered with drywall
which is like paper covered gypsum yeah
and it's a very conventional
building material because it's cheap and
easy to install but it's disgusting and
it's
it sucks the life out of you it's it's
just innervating to be in a room covered
with trouble so i just won't you know i
won't it's not more expensive to panel a
room with say pine boards like the one
i'm in right now and so i do i'm not
spending any time in a room with drywall
or overhead lighting or anything
fluorescent like why would i do that i
really believe in natural building
materials aesthetics are really
important to me nature is really
important to me
and so i'm just not going to do it you
know i'm never going to stay in like a
hotel room if i can help it i don't i
don't want you so that's right i'm
afraid to tell you tucker as you
probably know
that is your fascistic ethno nationalism
expressing itself
well it's funny like i'm architecture
really matters to me and when we were in
hungary last summer i gave a speech i
never write anything down so she's
giving a speech and i just launched into
this thing about architecture because i
really care about it
and whatever it's not you know i like
pretty architecture that elevates the
human spirit and not
sort of grotesque steel and glass
architecture that crushes the human
spirit i mean it's that simple it's not
i have no complex or brilliant views on
this at all they're very very normal
views but i really really mean it
so i give this speech and like david
frum when he said to me he's like oh
he's albert speer
he cares about architecture he's a nazi
it's just um it's hilarious
uh tucker coulson thank you so much for
coming on spectator tv thank you freddie
it's great to see you please come on
again and uh yeah good luck with
everything
[Music]
you